this morning when you were coming here
did you have a second of thinking what
I'm going to do what Conan O'Brien has a
tiny Radio Show in a little room was
there a point where you did a 180 and
started headed home
no no I just I didn't I I was uh I was
curious
I was curious about it oh
but then I got here and I
and I see this is a really kind of a big
deal
yeah I mean they're the this shit's not
free no I was very this is a
state-of-the-art studio designed here by
Eduardo really and uh nice man thank you
yeah a beautiful building that we have a
large complex we do many more like
probably
little there's uh three six people here
outside yeah outside there's another 20
people yeah what did they do well first
of all a lot of them are here because
you're here
yeah and I hate to throw people under
the bus but when Nick Kroll rolls in
they're not here I'm sorry Nick but
you're gonna take a bullet for this one
yeah
um who's Nick Crowley exactly exactly
exactly is he like Jerry takovsky he's
my Jerry takowski he's a very funny
brilliant uh comic and actor
yeah I threw him on the bus for no
reason other than his name came to mind
and I thought I'm friendly enough with
him that I can uh I can do this in this
moment
um but uh so that was undeserved and
Nick my apologies but you got a shout
out I'm talking here with Harrison Ford
and also uh yeah let me say his name
again yeah Nick Kroll yes there you go
now see All is Forgiven he's just
thrilled yeah he's thrilled now but no
we do have this is a big operation and
many many many people will hear this and
uh they'll say Conan does interrupt too
often
and he should shut up and he should let
Harrison talk nah
should let these other people talk a
little bit because they've got
microphones in front of them yeah and
you have not said one word can I
say something you know it's your last
day at work
so why not go for it well I I would just
like to say that I uh I dressed up a
little bit today uh out of uh you know
because I'm a huge fan and every single
person in the office has commented oh
you dressed up you look nice so do I
just normally look terrible I just put
on a button button down I'm sorry to
bring this energy the opportunity to ask
a question about himself
I'm sorry I'm sorry Harrison I'm sorry
one bullet on that you missed who is
this guy exactly yeah this is why I
don't let him have the microphone yes
all right so anyway what do you think
about what I'm wearing Harrison do you
like it
is it nice
sorry Jesus
you're wearing almost the same thing
they see we're almost matching oh my
gosh yeah sorry but I didn't bring it up
I didn't think we'd take some of Conan's
valuable time to talk about
what you and I are wearing
I have to say this is uh humiliating
this is humiliating this is humiliating
for me
it was humiliating through the minute
you walked through that door
your Colossians Colossus uh yeah uh and
then the minute you walked in here we it
was all diminished yeah
um your career is through Harrison it's
over okay I've just been told that uh
shrinking no longer wants you Yep
they're getting a new Indiana Jones oh
my God uh yeah been replaced Nick Kroll
will take over that role
[Music]
you're removing that's a little Mark
that keeps you on the belly button there
so that you always hear lighting is just
perfect and you removed it
um you're a carpenter do you like our
table what do you think
yeah it's nice everything is nice here
it's nice yeah we did a really good job
nice yeah yeah so what do you say You Me
Maybe we start hanging out a little more
regularly
well I thought we had this daily podcast
deal he was really kidding no that's not
I don't think he'll never see you again
it's over for years we're going to
Chipotle after I'm going to Chipotle
okay
um yeah I mean
I I don't have a lot of uh
time
left
I'm 80.
you look fantastic yeah
so you can be my friend
um
what would you what would we do uh uh
together you and I yeah uh I see us
getting a meal
um we'd get a meal probably you both of
the girls
our wives I think we should take I can't
say girl no I can't do that I think we
take the ladies I think my wife you take
your wife we go to a nice place we get a
and then
um
you and I take a little stroll
afterwards we lose the ladies you and I
walk along the ocean in Santa Monica we
look at the moon for a little while the
way fellas do
and uh it's a nice way to digest
and I'm digesting it right now
people will say yeah there's Harrison
Ford who's that tall lady with him
he's taken a new lover
why is he out on the town with that very
strange tall woman
and why are our wives
why are they nodding yeah why are they
letting it happen yeah uh they're better
than that yes they are they're well you
both married up
um Harrison
I want to say in all sincerity and I you
do not this is it
this is you're not someone who
encourages uh
uh you know sincerely so much
foolishness and laughing but uh I'm not
kidding when I say that people turned up
today who I haven't seen in a long time
just to watch you uh walk through the
door and uh you mean the absolute world
to people and you should have been in
this room last week when it was
confirmed that you were coming on the
podcast I believe Matt openly wept uh
blade jumped out a window yeah uh Sona
took an edible but she does anyway I do
that regularly yeah she's pretty high
although I am excited you're here yeah
yeah major yeah she's got a problem
not that bad yeah yeah it's yeah yeah we
all have an edible from time to time you
don't do that no I don't yeah I wish I
did I think I could be good for me uh
but my point Harrison and I eventually
do get to my point my listeners will
tell you that is that it was an absolute
Joy having you here and I will say again
you're one of my favorite funny people
you are so uh funny in an original dry
way and you're just the whole way you
come across I've always loved having him
on the show always and uh I love now too
that in shrinking people get to see you
be so hilariously funny
nope wasn't written down that was all
right that was all genuine no that's ten
times now I've done it oh yeah I've done
you ten times I've done you ten times
yeah you are done
that's it
nah just for me if this one
hey if this were it I would be quite
happy I'd be quite happy with that
seriously it's uh it was fun for me you
know what it's an honor to know you and
a blast and God you make me laugh so
thank you very much for doing this and
I'll be by in about 48 hours
no you'll be there waiting
personally turn me away it's been a
while since in the old days they would
throw a guy out of a bar by grabbing the
batch of his shirt and his belt and
throw him out that is how Harrison is
going to throw me off of his property
what a way to go man no nothing like
that you're a big guy
I'm an old man I hope never happens you
could beat this out of me yeah
trust me yeah
uh I say we never do this but Round of
Applause for Harrison Ford thank you sir
seriously thank you yeah yeah that's all
I got that's it you're free to go okay I
hope you enjoyed yourself right I don't
know why you're crying
I'm happy oh good I'm glad I came thank
you thank you for being here and
you got a friend thank you that's so
nice thank you very much that means a
lot to me yeah thank you what about us
yeah don't push it
okay I think that's a smart choice
honestly I respect that